now there was a very early time in my
career where I learned a very valuable
lesson I just finished up an internship
with a great game studio called
petroglyph games and I was actually on
an on-site interview for a new company I
got into a light debate with someone
during one of my interviews about what
things should be named more specifically
we were describing what an object is
that walks around in the world
unfortunately I probably got too deep on
that conversation and it turns out that
I was actually arguing with the
technical director of the project over a
naming convention needless to say I
didn't get the job the point was this as
game development goes on lots of people
have lots of different names for things
you should spend less time worrying
about what's something called and more
time worrying about what it does now
pretty much every game architecture out
there is gonna have some encompassing
object that has logic associated with it
that may or may not have a visual
representation and may or may not
actually be represented on the server
this is a basic object that every game
has you can call it an actor or an
entity or a Jabberwocky for all its
concerned trust me worry less about the
nomenclature of what things are called
you'll get more jobs that way